what's going on guys so i decided to
make a quick crash course on terraform
and if you don't know what terraform is
it's another one of those infrastructure
as code tools
and so it's really great for um modeling
your cloud infrastructure
through code and so for anyone that
actually wants to get more familiarized
with terraform
or learn another automation tool
especially with regards to the cloud
you know this crash course is going to
be really helpful for you guys and i'm
going to make sure to start from the
absolute beginning
so i'm going to walk you through how to
set up an aws account
i'm going to walk you through how to set
up and install terraform and that's
going to be across all operating systems
so i'll show you guys how to install it
on a mac on a windows and a linux
machine
i'll even show you how to set up a text
editor like vs code
which i highly recommend by the way and
then you know we'll get started learning
the core concepts of terraform and what
it has to offer
i'll show you guys how to create
resources on aws within terraform
i we'll take a look at how to modify
them how to delete them
i'll go over how terraform state works
and we'll take a look at how we can kind
of reference other
resources within our code and
i even have a like a mini project where
we'll get to
deploy a web server onto aws and
you know it sounds simple but there's a
lot of things that actually have to
happen
uh from a terraform perspective to get
all of that to work so
i think that'll be a great learning tool
and i think after this course or by the
time you finish it
uh you guys would have a solid
understanding of terraform and at that
point you guys can just kind of take it
from there
and then focus on specific topics that
you want and um
you know i plan to do a lot of a lot
more terraform videos so if you guys
have a specific topic
you want me to cover let me know and
i'll be happy to record a video and um
you know upload it to youtube
um but hopefully you guys enjoyed this
course and um you know if you guys have
any questions
uh just leave them in the comments and
um i'll try my best to answer them
to set up an account with aws just
navigate to aws.amazon.com
and here we can actually create an
account and create a root user so
we want to click on this button right
here that says create an aws account
and it's going to ask for some basic
information like an email address and a
password so just fill that in
and then you'll also have to provide in
a account name so i'm just going to call
this sloppy networks
and go ahead and select your account
type you're probably just going to
select personal if you're just making an
account for yourself but
if you work for an enterprise you may
want to select personal uh professional
and it's going to ask for some basic
information like your phone number your
country your address and you will need
to provide all of this information
and to actually create an aws account
you will actually have to provide your
a credit or debit card information um
you know throughout
all of these videos that i make we're
going to stay within the free tier so
you shouldn't be charged anything
uh as long as you shut down all of your
resources when you're done
and if you do end up getting charged
it'll be at most just a couple of cents
um but you know aws does require it so
you will need to have a credit
card to kind of follow along with
everything that i'm doing
and once you've finished adding in your
credit card information it will ask you
to verify your phone number so it'll
send you a voice
a voicemail or a text message depending
on what you select
so just wait for that text message to
come in and you can just pass in
whatever code they sent you
and we want to make sure that we select
the free plan so we're not charged
okay and at that point we should have an
account set
uh you will receive an email address uh
probably just asking
uh for you to actually confirm that you
created that account so we'll just go to
your
my email i'm gonna just like this and
then there should be
uh nope it doesn't look like we need to
actually confirm anything so it looks
like we're done
at this point we can just select this
button right here and just
go and sign into the console and so
we're gonna sign in as the root user
at this point um because that's all
that's been created
and so we'll just uh specify the email
address that we signed in with
and we're gonna have to pass in the same
password
all right guys so there you go we've
created an aws account so at this point
you should
have access to all of the resources
within aws
uh you are logged in as a root user so
if you want to create other users you
can do that at that point
but most of my videos i usually just log
in as the root user just for
simplicity's sake
to install terraform on a windows
machine there's a couple of steps that
we have to perform
and the first step is to download the
terraform executable file
and so to do that all we have to do is
just do a quick google search for
terraform
uh and we're gonna select that first
link it's most likely gonna be the first
link but if you wanna navigate directly
to their website you can just go to
www.tariff
and then just like this downloads button
right here and here we can see all of
the different operating systems that
terraform can run on
but we're installing windows we're going
to focus on that so we want to select
the 64-bit machine because that's what
my machine is however if you're using
32-bit select 32-bit
and this will download a zip folder and
so once that's complete you know just
right-click and go into
show in folder so just navigate to your
downloads folder or wherever you store
your downloads
and this is a zip file a folder so we
want to extract it so i'll just right
click
hit extract all and it's going to pick a
location so this is the default location
i usually just leave that be
and so we'll hit extract it'll pop open
a new window we can just close that out
but you'll see that right next to that
zip folder
is the new folder that we extracted and
so i'm going to go into there
and you'll see that we just have one
file in here and that's just the single
executable file
that terraform needs to run and so what
we're going to do is we're going to copy
this
file and we're going to create a new
terraform directory where we're going to
store this executable file
now where you create this terraform
directory does not matter you can pick
whatever location you feel most
comfortable with if you want to put in
my documents that's fine if you want to
leave it in downloads that's fine
the only thing that matters is you
remember the exact location of where
you're keeping this file
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go to my pc and i'm going to go into my
c
drive and i'm just going to make a new
folder here because that's where i want
to keep
it and i'm just going to call this uh
directory terraform
doesn't really matter what you call it
and i'm just going to paste in that
executable file
okay and like i said before you know the
location doesn't matter the only thing
that matters is you remember this exact
path
to this file and so to actually get this
exact path
go up to this uh search bar right here
well actually this is the search bar
whatever this is
and just click and you'll see that it'll
turn it into the exact it'll uh
transform it to the exact path so i'm
just going to
highlight that copy it
okay and now what we want to do is we
want to set an environment variable
uh that points to this path so i'm just
going to go to whoops
not command i want to go to env so just
search for those letters
and there'll be a button that says edit
the system environment variables
and then we want to select this button
down here this is environment variables
okay and we want to focus on system
variables so we'll hit edit
whoops uh we actually want to select our
specific environment variable
and the one we want to modify is path
okay so we'll hit edit
and so you'll see all of our environment
variables for the path
variable and what i'm going to do is hit
new
and i'm just going to paste in what i
copied so that path to that folder
hit ok hit ok and then hit ok
we're done okay and so if you have any
uh terminal windows open make sure you
close it
after you make that change uh if you
didn't have one open then don't worry
about that
and so now what we wanna do is we wanna
type in cmd
we wanna open up the command prompt and
i did not mean for that to be that big
and i'm just going to type in terraform
v okay and if you see this output
uh that means uh basically this command
is just going to tell you what version
of terraform you have installed
uh so right now i have version 12.26 you
may see a different version if you
download this in the future
uh the only thing that matters is that
we see this output so if you see
anything else
that means there was an issue with your
installation of terraform i remember
i recommend you just repeat the steps
that i covered in this video
there really shouldn't be any issues
that you run into just make sure that
once you're done that you see this
output
and that means you can now start running
terraform on a windows machine
now there's a couple of different ways
to install terraform on a mac
machine however my favorite way is
through using a tool called homebrew
and if you aren't familiar with what
homebrew is it's a package management
tool for mac os
so it can be used to install all sorts
of different packages not just terraform
on your mac so i highly recommend that
you you know whether you choose to use
this method or not
eventually install homebrew it'll make
your life a whole lot easier
and so to actually install homebrew
let's just do a google search for it
and it should be the first link so
brew.sh is the link that you want to go
to
and it's just going to give you this
command right here to copy so copy this
command
and we need to go to our terminal now so
i'm going to go into
finder i'm going to go into my
applications and then just look for
terminal so i'm just going to do a quick
search for that
okay and so this is what we want right
here if you aren't familiar with the
terminal
okay and so once the terminals open just
copy and paste
that line that you copied
and then hit enter and so this will
automatically install homebrew for us
you will have to provide your password
and then it'll just let you know that uh
you need to hit return to continue so
just hit return
and this is going to take a little bit
of time so i'll pause this video for now
and touch base with you guys once that's
done
alright now that brew or homebrew is
installed we can actually use homebrew
to install terraform and with homebrew
we'll have access to
a whole bunch of new commands mainly the
brew install command
so anytime you want to install a package
using homebrew all you have to do is
type in brew
and then install and the name of the
package that you want to install
so we want to install terraform so we
can just do brew install
terraform hit enter and it's going to
download the terraform package for us
and handle everything that we
need all right now that the terraform
installation is complete there's one
last thing we need to do and let's
verify that the installation went okay
without any issues
and to do that all we have to do is just
type in one command and that's going to
be terraform
dash v okay
and it should if the installation went
okay just print out whatever version
that was installed
and so you can see that i am running
version 12.26
however if you're watching this video in
the future you'll probably see a
different version most likely a higher
version number
but the only thing that matters is that
you see the version uh getting printed
out if you see anything else if you see
an error
uh that means that the installation did
not go as
as planned and so you'll probably have
to redo the steps that i covered in this
video but you know i don't think you
should uh
be running into any issues it's a fairly
straightforward process
homebrew will set up everything for you
so you shouldn't run into any issues
to set up terraform on a linux machine
the first thing that we have to do is
download the terraform package
so we can just go to www.terraform.io
and on the terraform homepage we just
want to navigate to that downloads
button right here
so we'll select that
and on this page just select the
operating system that you're using so
we're using a 64-bit
linux machine if you're using 32-bit
make sure you select 32-bit if you're
using freebsd then you know just select
the appropriate package
i'm going to select the 64-bit i want to
make sure i save the file
and then hit ok so at this point it
should be downloaded so i can just you
know select this right here and it's
going to take us to where we downloaded
it and it's a zip file so we will have
to extract it
and there's two different ways of
extracting it and i'll show you how to
do it through the gui
and i'll show you how to do it through
the command line depending on whichever
method you prefer
so i want to extract this zip file that
we just downloaded so i can just select
that and then hit extract
and then we'll hit extract again and
then it'll say extraction's completed
and then we can select show the files
and it's going to show us in our
downloads directory the original zip
file as well as the
unzipped terraform file so this is the
file that we really care about
however i want to show you guys how to
do this through the command line because
i think that's an important skill to
have so i'm just going to
move to trash okay and i'll show you how
to do it through the command line so
we'll just
go to our applications and search for
terminal
and we want to navigate to where that
zip folder is and so
i've set up my machine to download all
files to the downloads directory
that's usually the default location and
so we'll do cd
downloads and if i do an ls we should
see
the zip file and i can just do uh unzip
and then the name of the file however if
you don't actually have the unzip
utility
uh then you'll have to do a sudo you
know apt install
unzip first so that you can get access
to that utility
and then once you have access to that
utility you can just do an unzip and
then terraform
okay and you'll see that uh if you were
following along on the uh
the gui you'll see that it did create
the file for us and we can verify with
an ls
so we've got the original uh sorry we
get the original zip
folder as well as the terraform
executable file
uh now we're almost done however there's
uh there's one thing that we have to do
is we want to move this to a location
that will allow us
to run the terraform command regardless
of what directory we're in because uh
right now
we can only run it uh when we're in this
exact directory and it's kind of a pain
to always have to move to our directory
to be able to run terraform commands so
what i want to do is or what i want you
guys to do is
type in the command mv so this is going
to move a file to a specific location
and then we want to move the terraform
file
and we want to move it to slash user
slash local
bin okay and it's going to throw an
error
it says permissions denied so if you see
that error just run the same command
except put in the word sudo beforehand
so this is going to give us root
privilege
and you need root privilege to move any
folder into this specific directory
so hit enter it's going to ask for our
password
okay and so it looks like it's completed
so we'll just move to that directory and
just verify that it did actually move it
there
okay so it's in the user slash local
slash bin directory
uh now i want you to move back to your
home directory so you can do
a cd and then um tilde that's going to
take us to our home directory
um or just move to any directory if you
want to move to the root directory you
just move out of that folder
and now what i want you to do is type in
the command terraform
dash v okay and if you see this output
it should print out the version of
terraform that we downloaded so i'm
using version 12.26
however if you're watching this video in
the future you're probably gonna see a
different version that's perfectly okay
the only thing that i want to ensure is
that you see
some version get printed out that means
terraform is installed
and everything is working properly
however if it spits out any other
message
okay if it shows you anything else like
um you know terraform's not a command or
anything like that
that means there was an issue with your
installation and i recommend you just
you know repeat all the steps that i
performed uh
and and hopefully that fixes any issues
that you may run into
but at this point you're good to go and
you can start using terraform
uh and so you know in the next videos
we'll get started on you know actually
playing around with terraform
all right guys so there's one last step
to setting up terraform and this is
technically an optional step but i
highly recommend it
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to install a very powerful text
editor
now you can use any text editor of your
choice it's not going to make a
difference so if you prefer something
like sublime feel free to use that
however i'm going to be using one that's
called visual studio code
and so this is a free text editor that's
provided by microsoft
it's supported across all operating
systems and that includes windows
mac linux and it really is one of the
best text editors out there there's a
lot of people that use it and i highly
recommend you guys
use this if you want to follow along
with my videos because i'm going to
provide a lot of tips
within vs code that'll help make your
life a little bit easier when you're
trying to work with terraform
so if you want to follow along and get
vs code as well just go to
code.visualstudio.com
and the website should automatically
detect what operating system you're on
and so you should just be able to hit
this button
so you can see here it detected i'm
using windows but if you're on a mac it
should say
you know download for mac so just
download that um and uh
you know moving forward that's what i'm
going to be using but you know once
again if you want to use something else
uh feel free to do that but anyways once
you've got vs code installed i do
recommend
that you install uh an extension so if
you aren't familiar with the
extensions extensions within vs code
just give you some extra functionality
so to actually see your extensions uh
you know once you open up vs code it
looks like it already had it open but
you want to navigate to this button
right here so this is going to manage
all of your extensions
and just search for terraform okay so
once you search for terraform the first
one should be the one that you want
but just to double check make sure it's
the one by hashicorp who's the company
that makes terraform
and just do an install and so this
extension is going to provide us
a lot of features that make our life
easier so you can take a look at them
but
obviously auto completion is great
syntax highlighting
auto formatting you know all of these
are going to make your life a lot easier
when you're writing terraform code
but you know once you have that done at
this point vs code set up that's all you
really need to do
it's just going to behave like any other
text editor so you can create and
uh delete and modify files within here
so it's kind of like an ide but we're
gonna
use it for terraform
now that we've got terraform installed
and our environment for the most part
set up
uh the last thing i want to do is just
create a directory
that we can store all of our code in uh
and so within my documents i've created
a folder called
terraform project and then within this
folder i've created a folder called
project one so this is going to be
uh where we're gonna store our code for
our first project uh and so you know
feel free to make a directory wherever
you want if you want to keep it in
downloads if you want to keep it on your
desktop
uh just pick a location uh and once you
have that location set
to actually open a folder in vs code we
can just open up vs code
go to file go to open folder
and then navigate to wherever that
folder is select it
and then we can open it up all right and
so at this point it's going to give us a
welcome page which we don't care about
so just close it out and you'll see that
we've opened up project 1 within our
root directory and there's no files or
folders within there
now terraform is written in a language
called hashicorp configuration language
in a file that has a dot tf extension so
all of our terraform code is going to be
stored
in a file with a tf extension so what
we're going to do is we're just going to
do new file
if you right click here and just do a
new file i'm just going to call this
main dot tf
and the dot tf just signifies that this
is a terraform file and you'll see a
couple of pop-ups
if you install the extension just ignore
those for now
but keep in mind that you don't actually
have to call this main you can call this
you know file one you can call it uh
firstproject.tf
just make sure it has a tf extension now
in this file the first thing that you
have to do is define a provider
and in terraform we have this concept of
providers which basically
uh just allow us or it's a plug-in that
allows us to talk to a specific set of
apis
and if you go to their documentation
page so if you just go to terraform.io
providers index.html it's going to show
a list of all of the providers that
terraform supports
so if we download you know let's say the
aws provider
right whereas aws provider that's going
to make sure that terraform
downloads all of the necessary code to
talk to the aws api so that we can
actually create
resources within our aws environment
but you can see that you know terraform
even though it's really synonymous with
um
you know cloud automation uh you can see
that it's got a ton of providers
um outside of the cloud space it
obviously does support you know all the
major cloud providers
as well as some of the smaller cloud
providers but it also supports
kubernetes it supports
vmware uh it supports you know like
digital ocean
dns uh so it's it's got a lot of support
for a lot of different platforms
um just keep in mind though anytime you
wanna in uh work with any of these
platforms in terraform
you will have to install the necessary
plugins so that we can talk to
those providers and you might be
wondering well
you know we downloaded terraform you
know shouldn't that come with all the
code to talk to all these guys
well think about this guys uh you know
for the most part
are you guys going to be working with
all of these providers no each customer
or each user is going to have a
predefined set of uh providers that
they're going to work with and there's
no point in terraform
shipping out all of the code for all of
these providers in the installation
package
so instead on a per user basis or per
project basis
terraform will figure out which plugins
need to be installed based off of the
provider configuration in your terraform
file
and so we want to use the aws provider
because that's what we're going to be
working with so let's just click this
and it's going to give us an example on
how to actually
uh set that up and so you can see that
this is the configuration for a provider
and hopefully this is big enough for you
guys
um i'll just do a control uh let me see
if i can make this a little bigger
we'll zoom in 110 i think that should be
good enough for you guys
um but yeah this is all we really need
so we can just copy this
actually the version is optional so we
can just leave that out
i'll just do copy and i'll just paste
that in here
and i'm just going to delete the version
and now we're hard coding the region to
be us
uh and you know before i do that i kind
of want to explain
exactly you know what our regions if
you're new to aws
uh basically a region is just a location
where um
amazon or aws has a data center and so
there's a whole bunch of different
regions
and we can actually take a look at all
the different regions that amazon has if
we just search for aws
and log into our console
and so let's say my account we want to
go to aws management console to log back
in
and i'm going to be logging in as my
root user so we'll do
okay so this is our management console
and if you just select this button right
here
so right now mine says northern virginia
but yours may say something else
you can see all of the different regions
or data centers that the
that aws has and so it's going to
default and use whichever
data center is geographically closest to
you so i'm on the east coast in the u.s
so it defaults to using the northern
virginia data center or
what's referred to as u.s east one
however if you're in like california
it's going to default to probably u.s
west one and so what i would recommend
that you guys do
is that uh following along with me i
would recommend that you just
use us east one uh like i am uh it's
going to uh it's going to help prevent
any weird issues
uh with like amis because for some
reason like if you want to deploy an
ubuntu ami
uh in one region like us east one and
one region in like us west one
they'll have different names or ids i
don't know why aws decided to do that
but it can lead to uh issues because if
you're copying my code the ami instances
might be called something else
uh so just set it to us east one and in
aws or sorry in terraform set it to us
east one
and so that way um you know my resources
as well as your resources will get
deployed in the same exact region and we
should hopefully
avoid running into any weird issues all
right and so
now that we've got the provider set up
if we go back to the code it's going to
keep walking us through how to set
things up
and so the next thing that we have to do
is set up authentication
now authentication can be a bit tricky
with terraform
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
start off doing it the wrong way
right we're going to just hard code our
static credentials into our terraform
file
which is not recommended because
obviously if you're storing your actual
access keys
within this terraform file if you decide
to eventually
um publish your code onto you know
github or something like that
well then now all of your your your
credentials are being stored in github
and so
that can be a security vulnerability
however i want to start off doing it
like that because one i want to show you
guys how to do it every possible way
but also just to keep things simple for
now i promise we'll have some sections
later on
that covers how to do this in a more
secure manner but let's start off just
by
you know doing the bare minimum so that
we can focus on learning terraform
um before we start work worrying about
security or anything like that
uh and so basically uh all we have to do
is get our access key and our speaker
key and pass it into the provider
config and so to do that let's go back
to our aws management console
and you want to just select your profile
name and then just go to my security
credentials
and then here you want to select this
access key tab and you want to select
create new access key okay and if you do
show
access key uh these this is my access
key and this is my secret access key
so this is what i'm going to paste into
terraform
all right so i'm going to copy this
right here
paste it into my code
and then go back to here and then copy
my access key
paste it into here
whoops
all right so we've got our access key
set up in terraform
now when you actually create uh security
credentials within aws
you can only see these values once okay
so once
once you see these you won't be able to
get them again so make sure you store
them in a safe place
you can actually hit this download key
file and it's going to download a csv
file with all of that information so we
can just click on that
and it'll by default open up in excel
but you can see here this is where my
access keys are stored
so just keep that in mind because once
you hit close if you
try to look at your access keys you'll
see that we can see the key id but we
can't see the secret key anywhere and
amazon does that for
security purposes so make sure you write
that down however if
you lose it for some other reason just
delete your old one and then just
create a new access key and then you
should be good to go okay so now that we
have our
um provider set up and our access key
set up
the next thing to do is let's try and
figure out how we actually create or
provision a resource within aws
and within terraform the syntax is
actually really simple
and this is probably one of the nicest
parts of terraform and is really the
main selling point of terraform is that
regardless of what provider you're using
so whether you're trying to
create a resource within aws or a
resource within azure or gcp
it's going to use the same exact syntax
from a terraform side so that you don't
actually have to
learn the underlying api from you know
azure or aws or gcp
and the main syntax is going to be you
type in the word resource
and then in quotations you're going to
first provide the provider name
right and so in our case we would pass
in aws then you do underscore
and then you do a resource type right
whatever type of resource you're trying
to deploy
and then you have to give it a name and
then we're going to do curly braces
and then within the curly braces we
provide in all of our config options
these are going to be basic
key value pairs so key equals and then
you know some value
right and then key two
that's going to equal you know another
value so that's the basic structure
of how to create resources within a
provider
and so i'm just going to comment that
out for now and i'm going to walk you
through how to deploy an ec2 instance
within
aws and if you don't know what ec2
instances are it's basically just a
virtual machine within aws so if you
want to
if you want a windows server deployed in
aws you're going to be doing it in ec2
but you know you can obviously deploy
any type of machine that you want if you
want to deploy
linux if you want to deploy a database
you can all do that
within ec2 and so before we actually
deploy that uh within terraform i want
to kind of walk you through how to do it
within the aws console because i think
it's important to see
um you know how to do it in the console
and then how it kind of maps
to in terraform um but obviously if you
guys are already familiar with aws and
the console this is going to be really
trivial so you may just want to fast
forward the video
this is more from people that are also
kind of learning about the cloud
while also learning terraform at the
same time
and we can just go to our services tab
at the top select ec2
and then select instances
and you'll see that i have one instance
terminated in one instance running if
you just created an account
you shouldn't see any instances i'm
actually going to just delete this for
now
i'm just going to terminate that and i'm
going to just deploy a new instance so
i'm just going to hit launch
instance
and here we've got all of the different
amis that amazon supports there's
millions of different amis and you can
even create your own
uh however i want to deploy just a
simple ubuntu ami
okay and if you guys don't know what an
ami is it's really just an image
okay so there's going to be an ami for
ubuntu there's going to be an ami for
windows there's going to be an ami
for red hat one for fedora
and i'm going to search for ubuntu and
we're going to select the 18.04 lts
and you can see here this is the actual
ami id that's associated with this
ubuntu server
so we can hit select uh here we specify
the
uh the instance type the ec2 instance
type and so you know obviously there's
different you know sizes and speeds so
some have more cpu some have more memory
uh so obviously if you want a really
high performing server you want to go
down
to one of the ones at the bottom but
obviously the more high power they are
the more expensive
they are so for demonstration purposes
and for just learning
stick to t2 micro because it's part of
the free tier so you shouldn't be
charged as long as you shut it down
accordingly
so we'll just hit uh review and launch
and you'll get this page we'll just
launch that and it's going to ask you to
provide a key pair
for now just ignore that so we can just
say proceed without creating a key pair
and we're going to launch that instance
and if we select this view instances
button that's going to take us back to
the aws console and you can see that
it's now creating this new instance so
it's an appending state at the moment
but if you give it a few minutes
it'll eventually turn into uh it'll
it'll get colored green
which means it'll have been fully
deployed and then at that point you can
actually start using it
um but that's how we create an aec2
instance within aws using the console
let's go ahead and create it uh using
terraform now so that i can really show
you how
quick it is to do it through terraform
versus just using uh the console
and so like i said the syntax is going
to be just like this
so we're gonna do resource
and then our provider is going to be aws
right it's just based off of what's
provided here
uh then we want to do underscore and
then the resource type and you might be
wondering well what is the resource type
well
this is something that you actually have
to refer back to the documentation
so let's go to the documentation i'm
already on the aws provider page
and we're just going to do a control f
for ec2
i just keep going down actually that's
not what i wanted
here we go we want to search ec2 on the
left side so just open that drop down
menu
and we can just uh unexpand data sources
we don't care about that
we care about the resources section and
so what we want to do is look for aws
underscore instance so this is how we
deploy an ec2 instance within aws
and it's going to give you an example
and this is what i love about the
documentation their examples are super
helpful
but basically ignore the data once again
we want to focus on just a resource so
this is pretty much like the bare
minimum of what we need
we have to specify an ami and don't
worry about this goofy syntax
you know he's using variables and things
like that which we're not going to cover
yet
uh instead uh what we're going to do is
we're going to hard code the ami value
in the instance type
for now we'll ignore the tag so i'm just
going to copy this
i'm going to delete what i had started
already
and so you'll see that remember the
syntax is the provider
underscore and then the name of the
resource type so
in this case it's just instance and then
we have to give it a name so this is a
name
um that's not going to be you know set
in aws
this is a name uh so that we can
reference this resource within terraform
so this name is just going to be
uh scoped to just terraform it has aws
will not be
aware of this name so i'm just going to
give this name of
my first server
but you can call it whatever you want
okay and so the ami
we're going to delete that and to get
the ami we're going to deploy another
ubuntu server
and we'll do a launch instance and then
if we search for that ubuntu server
again
we want to go here and just copy this
ami and i recommend you follow these
exact steps
and not just copy what's on my screen
because amazon has a tendency to kind of
change up the ami ids
and so you may end up uh copying this
one which may get
changed in the future so you know go to
here search for it and then just grab
the ami
and we want to put it in quotations so
we just paste the ami in there and then
the instance type we want it to be t2
micro
just like we selected within the console
and we'll delete the tags
and before i actually run that code let
me go back to
services and ec2 and let's just verify
what we have running right now so i've
got two terminated and one running so
once this gets
deployed we should see two running
so make sure you save your configs uh
now what we need to do is open up our
terminal
and so you know if you're on windows uh
you can just hit the search button and
just search for cmd
to open up the command line um or you
know do whatever the necessary steps are
for
a windows or a mac and then you want to
navigate to wherever this project is
okay so for me that's going to be in
documents
and then i think it's called terraform
and not that one terraform dash projects
and then if i do a dir okay so then we
want to navigate to this project one and
here we're going to run our terraform
commands
however it's kind of a pain to have to
open up the command line
and then navigate to that folder instead
what you can do is
i'm going to move this off to the side
for now we can go to our vs code and
this is why i absolutely love vs code
we can go to new terminal
and it's going to open up a terminal uh
and if it's a
if it's a windows machine it's going to
open up a windows terminal if you're on
a
a mac it's going to open up a mac
terminal if you're on linux it's going
to open linux terminal
and it's going to automatically take you
to the project directory so you can see
it's already navigated to project 1
which is the root of our directory
and so here we can actually run our
terraform code instead of having to
kind of flip back and forth between our
code and and this command
line right here so i'm just going to
close this out because we don't need
that i'm just going to use vs code
moving forward
okay and the first terraform command
that you need to learn is terraform init
okay and so what terraform init is going
to do is it's going to look at our
config
uh in all of our terraform files which
are anything that starts the dot tf
and it's going to look for all of the
providers that we have defined so right
now we just have one provider
and so it's going to see that we just
have provider aws and it's going to
download the necessary plugins
to interact with the aws api so let's do
that we'll do a terraform in it
and let's actually take a look at what
the output is doing so you can see here
it's initializing the back end and it's
now initializing the different provider
plugins
and then it's downloading the plugin for
aws if we decided to add in a separate
provider so if we did like provider and
then maybe one for azure
well then it would not only download the
code for aws it would also download it
for azure
okay but you should see that terraform
is successfully initialized
if you see some other kind of error then
you may have to do a little bit of
troubleshooting but just make sure you
see that you know nice shiny green
output
okay uh and so we've got that set up the
next step we want to do is i want to
show you the
terraform plan command and the terraform
plan command
what this does is it kind of does a dry
run of your code so you can see
all the changes that will take place uh
it'll kind of show you you know if it's
going to delete any instances if it's
going to create new instances
if it's going to modify instances so
it'll just do a dry run so that you can
make sure that you're not accidentally
about to
uh break your production network or
something like that so i always highly
recommend you run a terraform plan
even though it is completely optional
it'll just be like a quick sanity check
so that you can just gloss over the
change that will be made and you can
just make sure that you're not going to
break anything
if you do terraform plan
and this may take a little while
depending on how much code you've
written but we just have one
instance so you should see that it
should be a minimal output it should be
fairly quick
but if we kind of scroll up a bit and
just take a look at what's happening
uh you'll see that it's going to color
code things depending on the action so
if you see a plus
that means it's going to create a
resource if you see a minus and it's
usually colored red i think
that means it's going to delete a
resource and if you see something that's
orange with a
a tilde that means that it's going to
modify a pre-existing resource
and so if we scroll down a bit you'll
see that right now
we're going to be creating an aws
instance an ec2 instance and you'll see
that we're using this ami
and then you'll see a lot of details are
not known at this point so it'll be
uh it'll be known only once we actually
deploy it uh
to aws because we won't know the id that
aws gives it until we actually deploy it
uh so you'll see that most of these
fields are unknown but except for the
ones that we've actually specified like
the instance type
uh source test check defaults to true so
some of the defaults will automatically
get applied
but this is just letting you know
everything that's going to get changed
so it's going to be creating a whole
bunch of things for this one instance
and so now that we've run the terraform
plan we can now run the terraform apply
to actually run
our code so we'll do terraform apply
and you'll see that terraform apply will
do something similar to terraform plan
where it'll actually
take a look at your code and then figure
out the changes that will take place
and so this is just another security
check so you can just verify that you're
not going to break anything
and it's going to ask you you know do
you want to make these changes so to
approve them
hit yes and it's going to run our code
now and hopefully
uh you know we don't break anything and
everything passes but you can see here
it's creating our first server uh right
now as we speak
so we'll let that run it's going to take
some time uh usually creating instances
can take a little while
um sometimes up to like 5-10 minutes
depending on what kind of instance
you're deploying
especially if you're on something like
azure i think azure takes a little while
for some reason well actually that's
pretty quick
but you can see that it completed and
it'll give you kind of like a quick
overview
of uh the total number of changes that
were made so we can see
one resource was added zero were changed
and zero were destroyed
and you know as usual you know just
because terraform says it finished and
completed we want to double check
within aws to see if that instance
actually got created so
uh you can see that this was the state
before we ran terraform so we've got two
in a terminated state
and one in a running state so if i hit
this little refresh button it's going to
just refresh it and you can see
now we have two in a running state and
this instance right here is the one that
got deployed
by terraform because you can still see
that it's in an initializing state
um but if we click on this and just kind
of take a look at the details
uh you can see that it's a t2 micro
instance like we specified
and you can see the ami so this is the
ami which is using uh
ubuntu 18.04 and so there you have it
guys you've successfully deployed your
first ec2 instance using terraform
and hopefully you can really start to
see the power of terraform uh just from
this simple example because
i mean what if we wanted to deploy 50
different instances right
would you want to manually have to click
through these windows 50 different times
or would you want to just copy and paste
a couple of
uh you know instances right here and
then you're you're good to go
okay so we've successfully deployed our
first ec2 instance
using terraform and what i want to do
now is i want you guys to try and guess
what will happen if we do another
terraform apply
i don't actually run this just trying to
figure out what would happen and
i can pretty much guarantee you that
your guess is going to be incorrect
i'm assuming most of you guys that are
watching are probably going to assume
that well
terraform is going to run this code
again and it's going to create another
ec2 instance
so we would end up with two ec2
instances and i'm going to tell you that
that is incorrect
in fact and the reason for that is that
terraform is written
in a declarative manner um and what that
means
is that we're not actually giving
terraform a bunch of steps to carry out
like uh like a normal program would
right so it's not going to go through
this code
and just run through each one step by
step right so if we wrote
if we pasted this one you know it's not
going to go
and say okay we want to deploy one
resource and then we want to deploy
another resource
instead what's actually happening is
that
uh we're telling terraform what we want
uh
our infrastructure to look like in the
end so we're giving it
the exact blueprint of what our
infrastructure should look like
and so if we look at our terraform file
here it says that we
should have just one aws instance in our
infrastructure
and that is it so no matter how many
times we apply terraform or run
terraform apply
we should always just have one aws
instance and that's this
specific instance right so that's why in
terraform we're not giving it a set of
instructions to carry out
we're trying to define what our entire
infrastructure should look like
and then terraform will go in and then
figure out exactly what needs to get
deployed
uh what needs to you know remain the
same what needs to get deleted
uh and so that our actual state in aws
matches what's uh being defined in our
terraform code
so if we do terraform well before we do
apply i always recommend you do a
terraform plan
so if we do a terraform plan again it's
going to tell us what the changes
that will take place and you'll see that
um it's actually
refreshing the state so if we look here
it's refresh it's
refreshing the state of our aws instance
that we actually deployed just to make
sure it's still there and there aren't
any issues with it
and that it matches what's here and then
you can see here it's telling us that oh
look
no changes were made or no changes need
to be made infrastructure is already up
to date and matches
what's defined in our terraform file so
if i do a terraform apply
hit enter
it's going to once again refresh the
state of our aws instance so it's just
basically uh talking to the aws server
just making sure that the instance is
still alive and working and then once
again
when we run the terraform apply it
figured out that look nothing needed to
get added changed or destroyed
okay and this is an important concept i
think it's a it's a little bit
challenging at first but
just know that once again it's
everything's being defined in a
declarative manner which is a little
different than a lot of other automation
tools
but you know keeping that in mind i want
to make a few changes
uh just to show you guys you know what
terraform will do when we start adding
uh you know extra properties to this
ec2 instance so the simplest change we
can make is adding a tag
so if you aren't familiar with tags
right you can give any
aws instance a specific set of tags to
kind of identify them
and so that you can actually search for
them and filter by those tags
so we'll go back to our code and
actually let's go back to the
documentation to see how we apply a tag
so this is all you have to do you just
do tags
and then you just provide in all the
tags that you want to give it so we'll
copy this
and i'm going to paste it in there
oops
i'm just going to change this tag i'm
just going to call this um
we'll call this ubuntu server we'll just
call it ubuntu so we're going to give it
a tag of ubuntu
make sure you save the code
and we're going to do a terraform plan
now just to see what changes are going
to take place
so it's going to refresh the state and
now it printed out some changes that are
going to take place
and so you know you'll see that anytime
we're going to change an existing
resource you'll see this yellowish
orangish color
with that little uh tilde and so it's
saying that we're going to change
something regarding this resource right
here that we already deployed
that's the my first server resource and
if we scroll down a bit
you'll see that this is the change
that's going to be made so it's going to
add in
a new tag okay so terraform was smart
enough to know that look
you know we know what the current state
is of our resource that's deployed on
amazon
and right now it has no tags um but in
our code we're telling it
to have a tag so then terraform goes in
and figures out oh okay i need to add a
specific tag
to this resource
so we'll do a terraform apply now
it's going to run that same check we
just did
and once it's doing that once it's done
doing that you can see that it's going
to make one change and we're going to
say yes
just so we can complete those changes
okay and it successfully completed that
it's changed one resource
we'll go back to the console we always
want to make sure that the changes
actually took place
don't just take terraforms word for it
okay
and so you can see right here already
the name got populated so
that's the special tag for naming a
resource
but if you click on the resource and
just scroll down to tags
someplace i forget where it is it should
be where is it
oh here we go yeah i forgot on aws we
actually select this tag
uh and so you can see here we've got our
tag which has a key of name
and a value of ubuntu
and if we remove that or comment it out
and then hit save we can do a terraform
apply again
and terraform is going to talk with aws
uh
api uh just to get all the information
about our server again
and it's going to see that it has a tag
but we're telling it to not have any
tags so then it's going to make the
necessary changes
and so all we can see here is that look
we're going to go from a name of ubuntu
to null which means we're going to
remove that tag so we'll run that
and it should remove that tag okay and
if we hit refresh
you can see that now there are no longer
any tags
now up to this point you know i showed
you guys how to create instances
as well as modify instances i think the
next logical step is to show you guys
how to destroy instances
and so if we want to destroy the
instance that we created we can do a
terraform
destroy
and once again when we run a terraform
destroy it's going to do a refresh of
our state
and it's going to show us what are the
changes are going to be made so you can
see here
um anything with that dark red dash
means we're going to delete it so
we're going to delete that one ec2
instance that we've deployed
and we're going to delete everything
kind of associated with that and so when
we hit yes
it should run that and it should remove
it from aws
all right so it successfully destroyed
our resource go back to the aws console
uh you can see if we hit a refresh this
guy should get removed
and so you can see it's now in a
terminated state and then i forget how
long it normally takes maybe like two
more hours and then
they'll get completely removed from the
aws console
but that's how you destroy uh your
all the instances that were deployed
using terraform
keep in mind though uh you know if we
had like i don't know
10 10 of these resources uh what's going
to happen is when you do a terraform
destroy it's going to destroy every
single resource
that was created by terraform so keep in
mind
uh you know if you want to destroy a
single
resource there are some uh parameters
that you have to pass in to actually
make that work
by default the terraform destroyer will
destroy your entire infrastructure so
you probably won't be actually running
that very often uh within
uh within a production environment uh
usually
usually you're just um you know doing
terraform applies and then you know
making changes and then applying those
changes
however i do want to show you another
thing that we can easily do
so first of all let's actually deploy
this once again
so i'm just going to do a terraform
apply we're going to have to wait for
this to get deployed again
okay and once it's deployed let's just
quickly double check that it's been
created so this is the new instance
that's been created
and what i want to show you is is really
the power of that
that declarative style of writing code
that i mentioned earlier
so instead of doing a terraform destroy
to destroy a specific instance
what we can do is just we can just
delete this code right here right and so
instead of deleting it i'm just going to
comment it out for now
which is doing the same thing as
essentially removing the code altogether
so if we hit save terraform will see
that look at this
and within our code there's no resources
being defined
and so terraform will see that it'll
check the state and it'll see that
there's actually an ec2 instance
deployed by terraform and it'll say hey
wait a minute that doesn't match uh you
know we should not have any resources
deployed
based off of this terraform file so let
me go ahead and delete that one resource
that we've deployed
if i do a terraform apply
it's going to refresh the state like it
did before so it's
it's refreshing that instance that we
created and it's saying whoa whoa whoa
wait a minute
right based off our code there should
not be an aws instance deployed at all
so let me go ahead and destroy this
sucker so if we hit yes
he's going to end up destroying it and
so that's just another example of that
declarative nature
of terraform and so you can use that as
a tool to
you know delete instances or delete any
resource within aws as long as you just
delete it from your terraform file
and then run apply terraform is going to
figure out what you want and what you
don't want so you don't actually have to
delete it from aws or do a terraform
destroy
okay so it looks like it's destroyed it
let's just go back to the console double
check
and so it looks like it's already
terminated it so it refreshed it for us
and so there you have it guys so that's
how you delete
uh resources within terraform uh
you can you can do it through the
terraform destroy or you can just remove
it from your code and do a terraform
apply and terraform we'll figure out
what it needs to delete
until now we've till now all we've done
was deploy an aws instance but obviously
anything you can do with the aws console
we can do it in terraform so i want to
start
taking advantage of some of the other
things that terraform can do
and i want to start playing around with
other resources within aws
so if you aren't if you haven't already
done so uh go ahead and destroy
the aws instance that you created you
want to do it through terraform of
course
i don't do it through the console so
either do a terraform
destroy or just delete this resource
uh and then run a terraform apply to get
that resource removed
and once you have it removed what i want
to do now is i want to explore how to uh
create a vpc and i want to explore how
to create a subnet within that new vpc
okay
and so if you don't know what a vpc is
it just stands for virtual private cloud
so it's just a
a private isolated network uh within
your aws environment so you can create
as many vpcs as you want or there may be
a limit but
you can have a lot of vpcs and then each
one of these vpcs by default
is going to be isolated from one another
and so
to create a vpc the first thing that we
want to do is always just navigate
towards the documentation so
if you just search for resource aws
underscore vpc
that's going to show you how to create a
vpc
and you'll see that the configuration is
dead simple right all you have to do is
just provide a cider block
uh and so this just means that um for
our vpc
uh the 10.0 16 is going to be the
network that's going to be used
for that vpc so let's just copy this
and we'll paste it in here to create a
vpc
and i'm going to change this name so we
can give this any name that we want so
i'll just call this my first vpc
and keep in mind that this is just the
name that's going to be used
within our terraform so anytime we want
to reference this
resource we can just reference first vpc
and if we want to give the name uh
within aws
we can provide it a tag and so you can
take a look at the configs here and then
this is how you do it so uh there's a
specific tag for naming things and
that's called name with the capital n
and we'll call this um we'll call this
our production vpc
okay and so this once we run this we'll
create a vpc
however what i want to do now is i want
to create a subnet
within that vpc and this is going to be
a little bit more challenging
and i'm going to show you why in a
second but if we navigate to the aws
subnet
resource and if you don't know how to
find it i the first thing i always do is
just do
terraform uh and then you know aws and
then whatever resource you're trying to
configure so if you want to see a subnet
just search for subnet
and it's usually going to be either the
first or the second one so we want
aws underscore subnet so it's going to
be the second link in this case
and you can see how to configure it it's
pretty easy right so we just specify
resource
aws subnet then a name and then
we have to specify a vpc id uh we also
have to specify a cider block so what
subnet do we want to use for that subnet
that makes sense
uh and then any necessary tags so let's
copy this
and let's paste it down here and so
i we're gonna change up a few things i'm
going to change this
to i'm going to call this subnet one
and the cider block 10.0.1.0
24 that's fine just make sure it falls
within this range
and then for tags i'm going to call this
prod
subnet
okay and here we have to specify the vpc
id
and you're probably thinking well you
know we haven't deployed this vpc
um how do we get the vpc id right i
can't go into the console and get it
because we haven't actually created that
vpc
oh this is where the power of terraform
comes in right we can reference
other resources that are being defined
within our code
so we want to reference this vpc that
we're creating and pass in the id down
to this field
and the way to do that is pretty simple
right all we have to do is we have to
specify the resource name so we'll do
aws
underscore vpc just like it is up here
then we do a dot
and we have to take the name of it so
we'll take this name and so that's why
the naming is important
paste it here and then we have to get a
specific property off that resource
and so every property has an id sorry
every resource has an id property that
we can access
so this value right here is going to get
the id of this
vpc that gets created from the line
above okay
and so that's how we can reference other
resources that are being defined in our
code right so you just
uh what i do is for simplicity's sake i
usually just copy
this whatever is between the quotations
and i just remove these two quotes put
in a dot
and then put in a dot id that's my
little shortcut
okay so i think we're good to go let's
try to run this and deploy it so we'll
do a terraform
apply actually let's do a tariff yeah
let's do a terraform apply
and so we'll see all the changes that
are being made and let's scroll up a bit
uh and so you'll see that we're creating
a subnet
uh and we're also going to be creating
our vpc and you'll see all the details
that are being passed into it so we can
hit
yes at this point and it's going to
deploy that vpc as well as that subnet
okay it looks like it's already done
that was super quick i guess it's really
just ec2 instances that take a long time
but if we go back to our dashboard um
what is this banner who cares anyways
let's go to services
search for vpc
and let's take a look and so you can see
uh by default there's a default vpc for
every user so this is the default vpc
that gets created so we don't
uh we can ignore that i just wanted to
make sure you guys understood that if
you were confused as to why there's two
vpcs
um but this is the vpc that we created
uh from uh terraform and if we take a
look at the details we've got the cider
block that we assigned to it
and then the tags obviously the name
being production and if we go to our
subnets
uh so there's going to be a whole bunch
of subnets here but once again these are
all part of the
default vpc that gets created uh and we
want to just take a look at the one we
created which is prod dash subnet
and so if we go here we'll see that the
vpc that this subnet resides in
is this vpc which is prod which is going
to be the vpc that we created
within terraform and then we also have
the cider block which is the 10.0.1.0 24
and so that's pretty much it obviously
there's a tag which is the name
which you can see right up there now
there's one thing i want to point out
you're probably thinking well
since when we create the subnet and
we're referencing the vpc
uh the vpc resource has to get declared
first
and what may be shocking is it actually
does not need to be defined first and
i'm going to i'm going to prove that to
you we're going to do a terraform
i'm destroy let that get destroyed real
quick
okay so it's been destroyed let's just
double check and make sure
okay and so that's gone and what i'm
going to do is just to prove my point
i'm going to copy this
or cut it i'm going to paste it right
above
right above the vpc so now within our
code we're defining the subnet
and we're referencing the vpc even
though the vpc is defined beneath it
and once again guys this is just to show
you guys that
the order in which you place your code
does not matter within terraform which
is a little confusing right if you're in
uh
if you're familiar with programming
right it always follows a sequential
order starting from the top and working
to the bottom
so let's make sure we save everything
and then let's do a terraform apply
and guys if you get tired of having to
hit yes whenever you want to
destroy or create something you can
always do the
dash dash auto approve and that's going
to skip that step so that way you can
just run it
step away from your seat go grab
something to eat and then just come back
when it's done
and so you can see here even though the
subnet was declared first
you can see that terraform actually i
realized that this window is probably
not that big for you guys
uh and so i'm gonna make this a little
bigger for you guys let's see
is there a way to do that maybe if i
just do a control plus
there we go
um but if you take a look at the order
in which things are created
uh you'll see that we create the vpc
first they create and it took three
seconds to complete
and then we created the subnet so
terraform does not care
which order the order in which you
define things because
terraform is intelligent enough to
figure out uh what needs to get created
first so terraform knows that a subnet
belongs in a vpc and since this subnet
is represent uh
is referencing the vpc that we're
creating it knows to create the vpc
first
and then create the subnet okay so
terraform is very intelligent
it can figure out what needs to get
created so you don't have to worry about
any of that nonsense it'll figure out
what needs to be done
however i will say this there are
certain instances where it can't
however uh if you look at the
documentation it'll always tell you
whenever terraform can't figure out what
order to create things
and it'll give you um a workaround so
like usually you'll have to pass in an
extra flag
that says one resource depends on
another but for the most part terraform
will figure out everything for you
now if you guys have been following
along you may have noticed that there's
a couple of extra files that gets
created on the left side
and so you may be wondering what those
mean and you know that's what i want to
cover in this section
so we'll start off with this dot
terraform folder
uh so this folder gets created whenever
we
uh initialize any plugins so when we did
a terraform in it
right the terraform in it it's going to
create that directory and then it's
going to
install all of the necessary plugins for
our code to run
in this folder so since we have just one
provider all of the code for the the aws
provider
is going to get installed into there and
just to prove that to you guys i'm going
to
delete this real quick
and it's okay it's not going to break
our code
it looks like it just deleted one of
those folders i want to delete all of
them
all right okay so they're all deleted
and if i try to do a terraform apply
it's going to throw an error saying look
at this we don't have a aws provider
and so what we have to do is we have to
initialize it again so if i do a
terraform in it
it's going to do that initialization
process and when it does that it's going
to create that folder
that we just deleted and there you go so
we see the dot terraform folder and it's
got
the configs for aws right here
now moving on to the second folder or
sorry the second file that you may be
wondering about
that's going to be the terraform.tf
state so
what this file is is that it represents
all of the state
for terraform and basically any time we
create
a resource within aws or any cloud
provider
we need a way for terraform to keep
track of everything it's created right
because that way
if we go to modify a parameter like add
an extra tag
or maybe change the instance type to
from like a t2 micro to another size
right it needs to be able to check uh
you know what is the current status of
that resource you know what are its
configurations and compared to what's in
the code
and the way it does that is it just
creates a simple text file
and so we've got this terraform.tf state
and it looks like it's in a json
format i can't remember if it is fully
json uh it may not be
uh you know don't quote me on that but
uh we can basically
store all of the resources that we
create in this state file so
uh you can see we've got the aws
provider
and if we just kind of look through it
real quick uh we can see all the
resources it's created so
we've got the first vpc that we created
and so you can see all the details about
that vpc
uh and then i think someplace there's
going to be a subnet so this is the one
that covers the subnet
and this is going to have all of the
information regarding the subnet
so this file is very important if for
some reason you ever go into this and
start deleting things
you will break terraform uh and so
terraform will have a
mismatched state from what's actually
being deployed into aws so never mess
around with the tf state file it's a
very important file and we it's
absolutely crucial
to the overall functionality of
terraform and just to kind of show you
how this state file gets updated i'm
just going to create another vpc
and so i'm just going to take this copy
this and we'll just paste it down here
and i'm going to call this
we'll call this second vpc
and i'm just going to change the cider
block and we'll change this
uh name to say dev
and might as well just create a new
subnet for that guy as well
i'll call this subnet2 and for the vpc
id i'm going to
reference this vpc so oops that's a typo
and we're going to just change this to
second
vpc and i'm going to change the subnet
to make sure that this subnet resides
within this cider block
and we'll call this dev subnet
now if i do a terraform apply
and then do a dash dash auto approve
and once again typos all over the place
now if we go back to our tf state file
uh we can take a look at it we'll see
that there we had subnet one already
that was already in there and then we've
got you know now we have subnet two
right so you can see that anytime we
create an instance or modify an instance
within aws
we're going to update our state file so
that we can keep track of all of that
information
all right guys so that's all i wanted to
cover in this video
until now we've only been doing very
simple tasks like creating an ec2
instance
uh or creating a vpc or a subnet and we
haven't even been able to log into that
ec2 instance
and so what i wanted to do was you know
with everything that we've learned so
far in terraform
i want to walk you through how to create
an ec2 instance
uh deploy it on a custom vpc on a custom
subnet and assign it a public ip address
so that not only can we ssh to it and
connect to it and make changes on it
we can also automatically set up a web
server to run on it so that we can
handle web traffic and you know this
task uh
it seems like a very simple task with a
couple of steps but
it's actually a little more complicated
than you think but luckily
we don't actually have to do anything
from a terraform perspective that we
don't already know how to do
uh and so i'm going to walk you through
that and uh i've actually outlined
all the steps that are necessary to do
this so there's nine total steps
uh technically ten we're gonna have to
do one step outside of terraform uh just
to keep things a little simple we could
do it through terraform but that would
get a little
more complicated um but just to walk you
through with these steps
uh we're going to create a custom vpc
and then
within that vpc we're going to designate
a internet gateway and the reason we
need to have an internet gateway is so
that we can actually
send traffic out to the internet because
we do want to be able to assign a public
ip address to this server so that
anybody in the world can reach
it then the next thing that we need to
do is we want to create a custom route
table
uh technically this would have been
optional but i thought it would be cool
to show you guys because these are all
things that you need to be able to do so
i wanted to make sure i walk you through
that
we're going to then create a subnet in
step four
and then anytime you create a subnet we
have to assign it to a route table
uh or then it'll get assigned to the
default route table for your vpc
uh and so this will just associate the
two together then we're going to create
a security group and the security group
is just responsible for determining what
kind of traffic is allowed to get to
any one of your ec2 instances so since
this is a web server we're going to
allow port 80
and port 443 for http and https traffic
we're also going to allow port 22 so
that we can ssh to it and um
you know obviously connect to it and
make changes to it
we're going to create a custom interface
uh and that's going to be
uh assigned to the subnet that was
created in step four
and we'll assign an elastic ip so an
elastic ip in
amazon world uh it's just a public ip
address that's routable on the internet
uh and then we're going to assign that
to the network interface we created in
step seven
and then finally we're going to create
an ubuntu server we're going to
automatically through terraform install
and enable apache and then we're going
to assign that
ip address or that network interface
that we created in step 7
to that ubuntu server and at that point
we should have a live running web server
and we should be able to connect to it
and you know do whatever we want with it
all right guys so uh you know before we
get started the first thing that we need
to do actually is create a key pair
within aws and the key pair is just
going to
allow us to connect to these devices so
aws
requires us to set up uh
set up access keys so that we can
connect to these devices so
to set up the keys we need to go to the
ec2 section
and then there's a section within here
called um
key pairs here we go uh and so you can
see i have one key pair here already but
i'll walk you through how to create a
new one so we'll just do create new key
pair
and here we'll just give it a name okay
so we'll uh call this uh
um oops
we'll just call this axis key you want
to give it a better name than this i
just couldn't think of one
uh okay how about this we'll call this
main key main dash key
uh so there's two different file formats
that you can use
uh go ahead and download the pem format
for now i'll show you how to actually
convert this to a ppk
if you want to use putty so uh you know
moving forward though
if you're mainly a windows user download
the ppk so that you can use it with
putty if you're using
mac or linux you're going to want the
pem file so
um you know download that but uh you
know for now even if you are using
a windows machine download the pam and
i'll show you how to convert it to a ppk
so we'll create this key pair and it's
going to automatically download this for
you so
just remember where it's getting saved
to so it's probably gonna get saved in
your downloads folder
and just keep that in mind okay so now
that we have our key pair set this is
going to
this key is going to allow us to
actually connect to our server once we
deploy it but
uh you know let's go through this step
by step and tackle each step
and you'll see that just how easy it is
to create all these resources and i'll
obviously point you to all the necessary
documentation so that
if you guys want to read up further on
it you can
and so the first step create a vpc you
know you guys have already done this
um but you know i'll walk you through
that so obviously i already forgot how
to actually um configure one
so just search for terraform aws vpc
this is all i do guys you know just
google it and google will tell you what
to do
and so here we're going to define a
resource a vpc resource
so i'm just going to copy and paste that
i'm going to keep this as the same cider
block it doesn't really matter for the
purpose of this
project uh now we need to create an
internet gateway so this is something
new
but once again the power of google we'll
do terraform
aws and then uh what was it called
internet gateway
okay so there's a couple of things uh
really the only thing you have to pass
in is the vpc id so we'll just copy this
and i'm gonna just go in here paste that
in there don't really care about tags
for now
and we need to pass it the vpc id so
remember we can reference
another resource within our terraform
code and so we'll just
uh reference this vpc so we do aws
underscore vpc then uh dot well let me
give this a more descriptive name i
don't like
main uh we'll call this um
prod vpc actually let's give this a tag
as well
why not
and we'll just call this a production
and so to reference this we'll do aws
underscore vpc
then dot then the name so prod
vpc and then we have to do a dot and
then id because we always want the id
property of this resource we don't want
the resource itself
and don't worry about giving us a tag so
that's all we need to do
now we have to create a custom route
table so this is something that's new
again so
we'll just search for that terraform
uh aws route table
and you know obviously we already have
this open so we could just kind of
navigate to wherever it is but
there's just so many resources it just
takes forever to find what you're
looking for so i always just google it
and so here we want the aws route table
and it's going to give us an example so
just copy this
and i'll take you i'll explain step by
step what each line is doing
and i'm going to give this a name we'll
call this prod route table
and we have to reference the vpc id so
we can just copy what we did with the
internet gateway
and we don't really need a tag for this
route oh let's get let's give it a name
i think uh we'll just call this uh prod
as well
okay and then now here this is where we
define the routes for this route table
uh so if you look at this uh what this
is saying is that for the
subnet the 10.0.1.0 24
we're going to send it to the internet
gateway however what i want to do is i
just want to set up a default route
which means all
traffic is going to get sent to the
internet gateway so to do a default
route if you guys aren't familiar with
networking
you just do the 0.0.0 0
and this is going to send all traffic
all ipv4 traffic
wherever this route points and this is
the old syntax of referencing
other resources but remember we're just
going to do it the same way we did for
the vpc
so let's find the internet uh the aws
internet gateway and so we just do aws
underscore internet underscore gateway
then you do dot and then we just
reference the name so we just give the
name of gw
and then we want the id property
okay and so that's all we have to do to
create a default route
and we can also create an ipv6 default
route i'm not using ipv6 but you know we
might as well go put it in
and so for an ipv6 default route it's
already been provided so you just do
colon
colon slash zero it's the equivalent of
this but for ipv6
and we can delete this and just point it
to the same internet gateway
and you know once again this is just
going to make it so that
our traffic uh in the in from the subnet
that we're going to create can get out
to the internet
all right now we have to create a subnet
where our web server is going to reside
on
and this we don't need to kind of search
how to do because we've already done
this before so resource
aws underscore subnet and then let's
give it a name i'm just going to call it
subnet dash one
and then we have to give it a vpc id
let's just grab what we did here for the
internet gateway and just copy that
a lot of copying and pasting here guys
and then we have to give it the um the
actual subnet
that we're going to use so the cider
block
and so i'm going to use the 10.0.1.0
24 subnet and there's also another
optional property so we can actually
specify
what availability zone we want to use
and if you don't know what an
availability zone is
uh within a region uh we it's not that
just
it's not that aws just has one data
center
uh within each region they actually have
a couple of data centers um i'm not
really sure how many maybe it's like
three to five
and so that way if one of their data
centers goes down in a region the whole
region doesn't go down so they have
uh redundancy and so you can actually
deploy resources to a specific
availability zone
and we can pass that in by passing in
the availability zone property
and then just specifying the name so
we'll just do us east
dash 1a and so there's going to be us e
stash 1a
1b 1c and so on but we're just going to
send it to 1a
and then we can give this a tag as well
so we'll set the name to
prod underscores
or dash subnet
and so now we've created a subnet we've
created a route table but we actually
have to assign this
subnet to this route table and so
there's another
resource uh resource type within
uh terraform that's called route table
association
and we'll just let me pull up the
documentation so you guys don't get
confused so we'll do terraform
aws route table association
and all this does is just it just
associates a subnet with a route table
and so you can see here we have to pass
in the subnet id as well as the route
table id
so we'll copy this and then we just need
to update the
subnet and the route table so we can
remove that
and pass in our subnet so aws underscore
subnet
subnet dash one dot id
and then let's grab the route table so
i'll just copy this
paste that in there remove the
quotations
whoops
and then just join them together with a
dot and then we want to grab the id
that's all we have to do for the route
table association we could just leave it
as the name of a because
we're not going to reference that
anyways uh so the next thing we need to
do is create a security group
this is something new again uh and so
it's always good to
make sure that you have a security
policy that's
really clamped down on only the
protocols that you need
and so we'll just search for that
and i'm just going to copy this example
and walk you through what's happening
so let's give this a name we're going to
call this allow
web traffic and we're going to change
this to
allow underscore web so this security
group is really just going to be there
to allow just web traffic so we just
want port 22 port 80 and 443
uh and uh description we can just change
this to allow web traffic
and we have to point to our vpc so
there's
we already know how to do that we can
just copy the one from the subnet
now this is where we actually apply the
different rules so we have ingress
policy as well as egress policy
so in this example what's this is saying
is that
we are going to allow tcp traffic on
port 443
right so the front port and the two port
just means it allows us to specify a
range of ports
so if i did four four three two four
four seven that means we would allow
ports four four three through four four
seven so when you just do the same
number it means we're allowing just that
port
uh and then this is the protocol so you
have tcp you have udp
uh and so on and then you have um we can
actually clamp down on what
uh subnets can actually reach this box
so we can actually put in like
our own ip address of our um of our work
computer or something so that only
uh certain devices can actually reach
this
uh and so sometimes it's best not to
open it up to the internet but since
we're creating a web server that's meant
to be used by anyone we want we want to
allow it so that anyone can use it
so we'll change this to zero zero zero
that default that means any ip address
can access it but if you just wanted
like a one specific ip
you could just do like a 1.1.1
you know slash 32 and then this would
mean that you know just that ip address
i can access it but we want everyone to
be able to access it so we'll do that
and we can have as many ingress and
egress policies as we want
and so this is actually technically for
https traffic so https traffic
i'm just going to call it that and what
we want is not just https but we want
port 80 and port 22. so
we can just copy this ingress rule and
paste it a couple of times
i'm going to hit save just so it formats
it and this is going to be http
and http resides on port 80.
tcp once again so all web traffic's tcp
and then we want it from any ip address
and then finally we want one for ssh so
this is going to be port 22
tcp and then yes any ip address and if
you look at the example
for the egress uh this is just saying
that you know we're allowing all ports
in the egress direction
and when you put in minus one for the
protocol it means any protocol
and um for the cider block it means any
ip address so this is exactly what we
want for the egress policy
what's more concerning is always setting
up the ingress policy
and we can change the tag to allow
call it allow web
all right um now we want to create a
network interface
so let's go to documentation for that so
terraform
aws network interface
and uh so i'm going to copy this
we're going to change the name i'm going
gonna call this um web server
nick and so we need to assign this
uh nick to the subnet that we created
so let's find our subnet uh where'd it
go here we go and
don't forget to grab just the id
and here we need to specify an ip so
what ip do we want to give the server we
can pick any ip address
within the subnet well not technically
any ip address you know aws is going to
reserve a couple addresses like the dot
one
uh and a couple other ones so i'm just
gonna do 10.0.1.50
so 10.0.1.50
and then finally we have to pass in a
list of security groups
and so let's pass in the security group
that we just created in the step above
and we can actually attach it to a
device now
but we're going to skip that and we can
actually specify what nick we want to
use when we actually go to
the provisioning section for an ac2
instance so we're going to delete that
part and we don't need that for now
and then now uh so this created the
private ip address for the host but we
also want to assign it a public ip
address so that
you know anybody on the internet can
access it
and to do that we need to create an aws
elastic ip
so if we search for terraform aws eip
all we have to do is just uh we can just
grab this as an example
uh so vpc equals true i can't i forget
what that actually does we can take a
look at the documentation
so this just means boolean if the eip
isn't a vpc or not so it isn't a vpc so
we have to set it to true
uh and then network interface so we can
specify what network interface we want
to sign it to which is the one we
created in step 7
so we can copy this
and then when it says associate with
private ip it's going to be the private
ip that we gave right here
and also i guess i forgot to point out
that um you know
here we're passing in a list of ips so
technically we could have given more
than one
um but we're just going to assign one
here and then we can just reference that
here
so do 10.0.1.50.
and now you know i told you guys that um
terraform
uh you know does not care about the
order and it will figure out
uh the order at which things need to be
deployed so that everything works
however there are certain gotchas and
this is one of the gotchas right here
is that the aws eip relies on the
deployment of the
internet gateway uh which is created up
here
and so if you try to do this through the
console and you try to create an elastic
ip
and assign it to a device that's um you
know on a subnet that
or in a vpc that doesn't have an
internet gateway it'll throw an error
because
um you know for for you to have a public
ip address you need to have an internet
gateway
so deploying an elastic ip requires the
internet gateway to be deployed first
before the actual elastic ip gets
deployed
and i guess terraform by default can't
figure that on its own
and if you actually take a look at the
documentation it even lets you know that
so it says elastic ips may require
internet gateway to exist prior to
association
so you can use the depends on to set an
explicit dependency on the internet
gateway
so what we can do is exactly what it
told us to do we can set a depends on
flag
and set that equal to the the internet
gateway that we created
and here we actually don't need to
specify the dot id we want to actually
reference the whole object and not just
the id
all right guys we're almost done we just
got one last step and that's to create
our ubuntu server
and here we're going to do resource
aws underscore instance and then we'll
call this a web
server dash instance
the ami so let's grab the ami from our
console again
so if we do launch instance
then we'll just search for ubuntu and
we'll grab
the first ami right here
the instance type we're going to do the
t2 micro again because it's free
and here we can also set an availability
zone
and i'm going to make sure this is very
important to actually set this to the
same one that we
used for our subnet and so if you
remember
we go all the way back to the top see
where is it
where's our subnet here we go our subnet
we passed in this availability is on the
dash 1a
and there's a reason why i hard coded
the availability zone because if you
don't hard code it
amazon will we'll pick
uh a random availability zone to deploy
that and uh
i've had a couple of times where uh
where the subnet would get deployed in
one availability zone and then my
interface would get deployed in another
availability zone and then
um i couldn't like combine the two
because they're essentially in two
different data centers so whenever you
get an option
make sure you hard code the availability
zone or then you could lead to issues
where it says like oh
you know you can't have your server and
you know one availability zone and then
you're submitted another one it just
creates all sorts of issues so
any time in the documentation it gives
you an option to pass it in go ahead and
pass it in
now if you remember the key pair that we
created uh we need to reference that
that we can actually access our device
and so let me go back to the key pair
what did i call it main dash key
main dash key
and now we can specify the network
interface we do network
underscore interface and if you're
wondering where i'm getting all of this
it's all in the documentation
uh so if i pull up aws terraform
instance
it's going to walk us through how to do
all of this um but what we want to do is
we want to scroll down
uh look for network interface
uh so there's a network interface
section
uh within uh where did actually it
didn't take me to the right section
here we go there's a network interface
section so we have to define a network
interface block
uh and this is what a block looks like
uh so you can actually create another
block within
our resource to define a few extra
uh parameters and so the first thing
that we have to do is
uh provide a device index and all this
is doing is that um
you know for any any ec2 instance that
we deploy we can give it a ton of
different interfaces right we don't have
to just give it one
so we have to tell it which interface
you want it to be right because
you know it's going to get labeled like
ethernet 1 ethernet 2 ethernet 3 and so
on
so we're going to make sure that this is
his first interface
and you can do that by specifying the
device index and setting it to
zero
and we want to set that to zero because
um you know it's kind of like uh
uh it's kind of like uh you know like in
any programming language the first
number you start with is a
zero instead of one so this is going to
mean that this is the first
uh network interface associated with
this device
and then we have to specify the network
interface id
uh so we just have to reference this
network interface so we'll copy that
and now guys this is where the actual
magic happens here uh so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna tell terraform
uh to on deployment of this server to
actually
run a few commands on the server so that
we can automatically install
apache and the way to do that is to use
the user
underscore data block and what we have
to do is we have to pass in and it's
going to look a little goofy
but we just say eof
and i forget what this stands for um but
you just put that in there
and then now we just type in all of the
commands we want to run so just like
with any batch script
we want to start off with the with this
goofy header that you always need
and then now we just specify all of the
commands that we want to run so
we'll do a sudo apt update dash y
we'll do a sudo apt install apache 2-y
and then we'll do a sudo system ctl
start
apache 2
and then finally this last one is kind
of optional but what i'm going to do is
i'm going to copy some text
to the index.html file that gets served
by the web server
so that we can confirm that you know all
of these commands actually worked
and i'm just going to say um we'll say
echo and then we want to send a string
of text we'll just say
your very first web server
and we want to redirect that to slash
var
www html
index.html and hopefully i wrote all of
that without a typo
and then you know obviously you guys can
run any command that you want so you can
put in whatever command so you can
install
you can install any package um you know
you can
modify and configure files all from here
uh but once you're done entering in all
your commands you just do eof
so eof at the top starts all of the
configs and then the eof at the bottom
basically tells terraform that we're
done
and then lastly let's give it some tags
so we'll say name equals and we'll just
call this web server
let's hit save and now we're going to do
a terraform
apply and it looks like i messed
something up so let's see
uh depends on what happened here
a static list expression is required ah
okay
i already know my mistake so when you
use the
depends on parameter you actually have
to pass it in as a list
and so the reason we pass in this list
is because we can actually specify um
multiple things that we need to wait on
before we actually run the elastic ip so
if we wanted to
make sure that you know the the vpc got
created we can specify that as well as
the subnet and so on so you can put in
as many uh criteria as you want so
that's why we have to pass it in as a
list let's do a terraform apply again
hopefully it goes through this time
looks like it's good so far we'll do yes
and let's just uh now it's time to start
praying
and it looks like we got another error
on line 25
let's see what happened here
yep and i already figured out the
mistake this should be
uh under the aws route table uh this
should not be egress only gateway id
this should just be gateway id like it
is up here and that was just because i
copied and pasted it and i forgot to
change it
um but you know just to make sure you
guys understand what's happening here
um all we're really doing is we're just
saying that um our default route for
ipv4 ipv6 is going to go towards the
internet gateway so that we can get out
to the internet
all right it looks like it's done guys
uh so let's just take a look
um let's just verify in the console that
everything is okay
and so um we'll go do let's go to our
ec2 instance let's see if it got created
and so we've got one that's initializing
right now and that's our web server you
got the previous one
obviously i did a drive run before this
video although i still messed up a whole
bunch of things
but this is our ec2 instance i think
things look good
obviously we can go through each and
everything you know make sure our vpc is
good make sure our subnet's good make
sure our route table is good but that's
just a waste of time because i already
know they're okay
instead what i want to do is i want to
actually uh show you
how we can connect to this device or
actually uh let's wait till this is
finished initializing and once it's
initialized let's just navigate
to this ip address and see what happens
so i think it's probably at this point
already running so let's just
go to that and then we'll just go to the
ip address so copy the ip address
and your web browser go to that and you
can see your very first
web browser so this just confirms uh
that we installed apache on our server
and we copied that text to the
index.html file to get served to all the
users
and so that just confirms that
everything is working okay however
now what i want to do is i want to show
you guys how to actually connect to that
device
since it has a public ip we can actually
ssh to it and the way to do that it's
going to vary depending on
what operating system you're on so if
you're on windows i'm gonna walk you
through that now and then in a second
i'll show you guys how to do that in um
on a linux or um or a mac
machine so if you're on windows the
first thing that you need to do is
download a software called putty
it's a little annoying that we need to
use putty but uh just search for putty
and then let's see if i can
so just download it here click this
button and then um
you can just download the installer so
get the 64-bit if you're using 64-bit
uh or get the um 32-bit if you're using
the 32-bit so
after you install it uh just go to your
search bar
and just search for putty and you'll see
that there's two applications that
actually got installed there's putty and
puttygen
and the first thing that we need to do
is we actually need to open up puttygen
and the reason we need to do this
is because this is a pem file and i told
you guys that
um you know there's the there's the ppk
file or pkk i forget which one it is i
think it's ppk
and then there's the pem file so linux
machines like to use the pen file
however uh putty likes to use the pkk
file or the ppk file whatever it is i
can't remember
and so we have to convert this pem file
to the right format to be able to use it
on a windows
machine so the way to do that is open up
the puttygen
application like i just showed you and
hit this load button
and here select all files
and we've got this main dash key dot pem
so hit open and it's import this
and then all we need to do is select
save private key
and then it's going to give you this
warning go ahead and ignore it and just
hit yes
and then give it a name so i'm just
going to call this main key
again and it's going to save it as a ppk
file so i'll have a pem version as well
as a ppk version
so i can use it on either machine
i'll hit save and i think it should have
created it
so we can just double check
and let me go to my downloads folder
real quick
and if i move that over here yeah you
can see that now we have the main
dash key ppk file as well as the pem
file
so now what we need to do is we'll close
out this puttygen and we're going to
open up
the regular putty device or the putty
application it keeps opening up on the
other window which is kind of a pain
and now let's go back to our console and
the way to connect to one of these
devices
hit this connect button right here and
it's going to give you all the
information on how to connect
uh to this device and so you'll see that
the user for this device is ubuntu and
then you know it's going to also give us
the ip address but we can actually
confirm the ip address here
the important thing is we know that we
need to
log in using the user as ubuntu so we'll
do
ubuntu and then to specify the ip
address you do at
and then the ip address so let's copy
this ip address
paste it in now we have to log in using
that ppk file and to tell putty to use
that go into this
ssh right here and i know this text is a
little small for you guys i don't know
how to make this bigger unfortunately so
you're just gonna have to bear with me
uh hit the auth button and then there's
a section that says private key file for
authentication
so hit browse and then just find that
main
key ppk file hit open hit open again
and once again this opened up in another
window
and it looks like i'm running into some
issues so i'm not sure what happened
here
let me close this out i'm going to open
up my terminal
i should be able to ping three two two
eight at two four eight
uh two five two
or maybe not well that's a problem
oh wait no we didn't allow pings
let's just make sure this works again
okay so that's good
now why is it that we cannot reach this
device so let's check our security group
let's view inbound rules oh look at this
guys i messed this up
you see we're allowing port 2 and we
don't care about port 2 we want port 22
so let's go back to our terraform file
let's see where uh where i messed that
up
here we go this is where i mess it up so
this should be port 22.
if we hit save and then do a terraform
apply it should
apply this on the fly real quick for us
all right that's been done let's just
double check here so we'll go to
view inbound rules now it says port 22
and let's open up putty again and just
perform the same exact steps
we want to go to ubuntu at and then
copy this ip address
go to ssh go to our authentication
browse find our main key ppk file
hit open and
it should pop up with this security
alert so just hit yes
and at this point you should be logged
in using putty so um you know
we're on a linux machine you can run any
command you want but you know if we want
to verify apache is running let's just
do a system
ctl status apache two
i spelled that wrong
and so and so it's running and so that's
how we
um you know connect to one of these
boxes on a windows machine let me show
you how to do it on a mac machine
and let me just copy this pen file to um
to my mac machine real quick
and so remember we want the pem file on
a mac and on a windows we want the ppk
okay guys to connect to our web server
or an ec2 instance from a mac or linux
machine
steps are going to be identical the
first thing that i want you to do is go
to
your web browser and just go to aws
and log into your console because it
actually kind of walks you through
how to do it step by step it's actually
really easy so if we go to our ec2
section
and go to running instances i'll go to
your web server and then just hit
connect
and so these steps are all you have to
do so we have to do chmod 400 and then
the name of that pen file that we
downloaded
and that's just going to set the
permissions to the correct values
and then we have to connect to it so the
way to connect to it is you go to your
command line you do ssh
dash i then the name and location of
your pem file
and then we want to connect to it doing
ubuntu at and then the ip address so
that's all you have to do
so let's go to our terminal and let's
find that pen file so i saved it in my
downloads folder
and so i've got that main dash key dash
pen so we'll do a ch mod
400 main dash key
pem
and now to actually connect to the
server we do ssh
dash i and then the name of the file so
main key pem
and then now we do ubuntu at and then we
need to get the ip address so let's go
back here
let's copy the ip address
and then paste it in
and then we hit enter and we should get
this same warning that we got on the
windows machine so we'll hit yes
and there you go you're now connected to
the device and you can run any commands
so that's all i wanted to show you guys
in this video hopefully you learned a
lot
you know i showed you guys how to create
a lot of different resources these are
all things that you're going to need to
know how to do
and uh hopefully at this point you guys
should feel um
relatively comfortable with navigating
around terraform and creating and
deleting
resources uh definitely go ahead and um
you know once you're done with this
project
uh do a terraform destroy because we did
deploy a lot of things and i don't want
you guys to get any kind of unexpected
bills
even though we are in the free here so
just do a uh terraform
destroy and then we can just do a dash
dash auto
proof but you know what what happened
here
terror form and oh not the story
um but you know we still have a lot of
things to cover when it comes to
terraform you know
uh you know you get a chance to cover
variables
uh or uh or modules or things like that
so there's still a lot to cover with
terraform
um i think that's going to wrap it up
probably for this video i'll make some
follow-up videos
if there's any topics you guys want me
to cover let me know and i'm happy to do
it
uh you know terraform has been something
that i really enjoy working with so if
you guys want me to do more terraform
videos
um also let me know and i'll be happy to
do any videos or any topics that you
guys want
in this video i'm going to go over a few
extra terraform commands that i think
are helpful
and if you've already destroyed the the
project that we created in the last
video
go ahead and deploy it again or at least
just deploy a few resources we need a
few resources deployed so that we can
actually
take a look at the output and so i've
already done that so i've already um
you know run this uh terraform config
and so we have
several different resources deployed and
the first command that i want to show
you guys
is uh terraform state list
and by the way guys if you don't know
what commands to run
um i always just start off with
terraform and hit enter and you'll see
that the command line will kind of help
you
uh you know with the different commands
that are available so these are all the
options that we have
and so right now i want to focus on the
state
uh sub command so where is this i think
it's terraform
oh it's down here uh so the terraform
state sub command so if we do terraform
state and then hit enter you can see all
of the commands that we have at our
disposal
so we've got list this is the main one
that i'm confirmed uh concerned with so
if we do a terraform
state list this is going to list out all
of the resources that we have state for
so any resource that i've created in my
topology
uh you know we're going to have an entry
in this output and so you can see we
have the elastic ip that i created
we've got the web server that i created
as well as the internet gateway
the network interface the route table
the route table association the security
group the subnet and the vpc
and if you actually want to see detail
uh regarding
any one of these resources you can do a
terraform state
show and then just copy one of the one
of these items so if i want to see
detailed output for
the elastic ip i can copy that
and paste it in oops it looks like i
didn't copy it hold on
terraform state list
and just copy that
and sorry we need terraform state show
all right and so you can see it's going
to give us a detailed output regarding
that state and it's going to include a
lot of information that would normally
only be stored in the aws console so we
can see
the ip address we can see the
association id
we can actually see the actual id of the
resource that gets created in aws
then we can see the id of the instance
this elastic ip is assigned to
as well as the network interface and we
can even see the public ip and this is
super helpful because there's going to
be a lot of times when you deploy
something
and you want to know what the ip address
is especially the public ip and normally
you'd have to do it
through the aws console but you know we
have this command so that we can just
verify it from the command line really
quickly without having to log
in and we can do this with you know
really
any one of the resources that we've
deployed so if you want to see more
detail regarding the web server that we
deployed
we can copy this and just take a look at
that and just do a terraform
state show and you're going to see all
the information that we have regarding
that server that we deployed so we can
see the id
uh we can see you know the ami that was
used what availability zone it was
deployed on
we can see its public ip here as well
and uh you know a couple other details
that would once again normally only be
available in the aws console
so you know those are the two commands
keep those in mind so remember terraform
state
list and then terraform stage show those
are going to be the two big ones
in the last video i showed you guys how
to verify the
state information for resources that
we've deployed
using the terraform stage show command
and the terraform state list command
and those will allow you to see
information like the resource id
it'll allow us to see uh information
about you know like what's the public
and private ip
of a ec2 instance and so we can see a
lot of detail about these resources that
we've deployed ourselves
and it's super helpful super handy but i
want to show you another thing that we
can do to actually see that information
right because you know after you deploy
something you know we can always do a
terraform state
state list and then whoops terraform
state list
and so if we wanted to extract the um
public ip of the
elastic ip that we created you know we
can always do a terraform state
show and then just copy that
and you can see here that we can
actually see the public ip
under the public ip property of this
resource that we created
but there's going to be times where you
know it's kind of a little inconvenient
to have to always do terraform
state list and then terraform state show
for all of the details that we want
you know what if we could get terraform
to automatically print that out when we
run a terraform apply
and well guys there is a way to do that
and that's by using the terraform output
command so
you know any one of these properties
that we can see by doing a terraform
stage show on any one of these resources
we can tell terraform to automatically
print those out when the resources are
created
and we can do that using the terraform
output command i'm going to show you
just how simple it is
so as i said before you know one of the
main use cases
is extracting the public ip uh that's
going to get assigned to an elastic ip
or a ec2 instance that gets created
so we can just do a terraform oops not
terraform uh we could do the output
and then we have to define an output for
this so i'm just going to call this my
server
underscore public underscore ip
and then here we just assign it a value
so we get the value from
uh from this right here
from this terraform stage show so to get
the value what we have to do is we have
to pass in the name of our resource
which is aws
underscore eip uh underscore or
dot one and then we wanna grab the
public ip property
okay and so we can go down here and we
just say value equals
aws underscore eip dot one
dot public underscore
ip okay and so that'll get this property
and it'll print it out into the console
when we run terraform apply
so let me save this and we'll do a
terraform apply
and then dash dash auto approve
and let's just wait for that to run and
i want you to notice what happens
uh at the end
right look at that so the output that we
created it's going to print out our
server public ip
uh so that we don't have to go into the
terraform state and verify it ourselves
and so this can come in handy because
you know we can print out all the
details that we are concerned with
without having to actually go in and
check the states ourselves
and we could obviously uh you know grab
any other property so as an example
let's say uh
let's see what other properties we can
grab that i think would be cool let's do
terraform state list
and then terraform state show and then
let's check
our our web server instance
so let's say we want to grab
the private ip of our server as well as
um the ami that's being used or no i
think the id would be cool because we
we're hard coding the ami so
who really cares about that we already
know what it is uh and so we can just
define another
terraform output so we'll do output
then we have to give it a name so just
give it any name you want i'm just going
to say
server we'll call this a i don't know
server
private ip
and i'm going to do value and then
remember we have to set this equal to
our resource so we'll copy our resource
name
and remember we need to get our property
name so this is going to be called
private underscore ip
and i can't remember if we can put two
values in here but let's just give that
a shot
and so let's see if i just copy this and
let's print out the id
and let's try a terraform apply again
yep so it looks like we can only set it
once so we'll have to create another
output
and we'll call this um server id
and i'm just going to move this down
here
all right so now when we do a terraform
apply we should see three different
output
and there you go there you go guys so
you can see the three different outputs
that we've defined we've got the server
id we've got the private ip
as well as the public ip and um you know
you can always
verify the outputs by doing a terraform
output and it's going to print out all
the outputs for us
however if you decide to add another
output
uh you know into your config but you
don't want to do a terraform apply
because technically terraform apply
could potentially make changes to your
network and if you're in a production
network
you don't want to accidentally deploy or
delete something
uh just to see what the output is so uh
you know if you're in that situation
you can always do a terraform refresh
and this should um you know just refresh
all of your state and it'll run the
outputs
again so that you can verify them
without actually you know deploying
anything or
doing an actual apply
with the declarative nature of terraform
it's kind of an all or nothing situation
when you want to deploy
uh your terraform config or destroy it
so you can either spin up everything
that's been configured in your terraform
file or destroy all of it
however terraform does understand that
you know there's going to be instances
where you want to just delete an
individual resource
or if you're just trying to roll out
with the deployment to do
stage deployments where only certain
resources are to play deployed one day
and then the next day another set of
resources are deployed
and so we can target individual
resources within our configs
to either apply or destroy them by
passing in the dash target flag
and so i've got a whole bunch of
resources deployed and let's say that i
just want to
delete this web server right here well
we can do a terraform
destroy and then we can pass the target
flag and then i'm just going to provide
the name of the resource
so we'll do aws underscore instance dot
web dash server dash instance and so
this should leave everything else on in
my configs untouched
so all of these you know the route
tables the subnets all of that should
remain untouched
and terraform should just delete this
one ec2 instance
let's give that a shot and let's see
what happens
all right and so if we go up here just
to see what's going to change
you can see that we're going to be
destroying just one resource and that's
that web server that we
uh targeted and so you can see here
only one resource is going to get
destroyed if i hit yes it should then
delete just that server
all right so it successfully destroyed
just that one resource
and if we want to do the exact opposite
thing and deploy just this one resource
we can use the dash target flag once
again
to accomplish that terraform
apply dash target then the name of the
resource that we want to deploy so in
this case we're just deploying
just that web server that we just
deleted
and i'm going to move
the apply to here
all right and if we take a look at the
summary of the changes that will take
place we can see that it's going to add
one resource which is exactly what we
want
we'll hit yes and let's just double
check that everything works okay
and there you have it guys we've
deployed just one individual resource
from our terraform config
alright so this was just a short video i
just wanted to make sure that you guys
understood how to
target an individual resource or
individual resources if you want to
deploy just a couple
and so that just hopefully gives you a
little bit more flexibility on
maintaining your infrastructure
using terraform now just like any other
programming language
terraform does allow us to make use of
variables so that we can reuse values
throughout our code without having to
repeat ourselves
and right now uh inside this example
configuration file
i've got just a vpc being defined so
we're going to create a vpc
and then we're going to create a subnet
within that vpc so nothing new up to
this point you guys should already be
familiar with how to do this but what i
want to do is i want to
take this cider block definition for
subnet one and store this value right
here the 10.0.1.0
24 subnet in a variable and to define a
variable in terraform it's very easy all
you need to do is just type in variable
and then the name of the variable so we
can give it any other name
so we'll i'm just going to call this
subnet underscore prefix
okay and within this variable definition
we can pass in
three uh arguments or three parameters
and all three of them are completely
optional so we can technically leave
this empty
but the three options are we can give it
a description
uh we can also give it a um
a default value as well as
a type okay and so once again all three
of these are optional but a description
is exactly what it sounds you can
like you can just give it a description
so we'll just say
um this
is going to represent the cider block
for the subnet
the default value so the default value
is just going to be what terraform is
going to give this variable if we don't
actually pass in a value for this
variable
so i'm going to leave this blank for now
and just comment that out we don't need
it
and then the type so we can actually
perform uh type constraints on variables
so that when a user enters in a value
we can make sure that they enter in the
proper type for this variable so if
we're expecting a string
you know we can say type equals string
and there's a couple of different types
that terraform supports so you know it
supports strings it supports numbers
booleans lists maps sets
objects tuples and if you're not sure
what type you're going to use uh that
and if you're not really sure what type
needs to be passed in you can always
just pass in the any argument
uh to say that we support any type but
you know we can just leave this blank
for now and we'll come back to using
uh type constraints so for now all we're
going to do is just provide a
description
and i'm going to hit save and let's see
what happens when we actually run our
code now well actually one more thing
uh we actually have to you know use that
variable someplace right so to actually
reference a variable in our code
it's very simple so i'm going to delete
this subnet right here
and to reference a variable we just type
in var and then dot
and then the name of the variable so
that's going to be subnet underscore
prefix all right and so
you can see that nowhere in our code so
far have we actually defined a value for
subnet prefix we just provided a
description
so if we do a terraform apply let's see
what happens
and look at that so any variable that
isn't assigned a value
terraform will actually prompt the user
to enter in a value for that
so i'm going to give this a value of
10.0.1.0
24. and so this value that i'm passing
in is going to get assigned to subnet
prefix
and so once the aws subnet resource runs
it's going to
pull that value and store it for the
cider block so let's hit enter let's
wait for that to run
okay so the resource has been added
let's take a look at the aws console
just to see
uh if that actually worked so i'm going
to go to this prod subnet
and so you can see here that it got
passed in a 10.0.1.0
24 prefix and so that just confirms that
our variable is working uh now it's kind
of a pain to have to
uh get prompted for what the value of a
variable should be so
there's other ways of passing in uh
values or assigning values to a variable
and one of those is through a command
line argument
and so what we can do is i can do a
terraform well first let's do a
terraform destroy
so we can delete those resources and it
looks like i spelt something wrong yep
destroy and you'll see that when it
needs to get destroyed it's going to ask
you uh for a value for that uh
that variable that we defined but for
destroying it doesn't actually matter so
you can just
technically just leave it blank and it
should be able to destroy things just
fine
we only really care about passing in the
proper value when we're doing an apply
all right so we've destroyed the
resources now let me show you guys how
to assign a value
to a variable through a command line
argument so if we're going to do a
terraform apply
we can also do a dash of r
and then set a value for a variable so
we're going to reference this subnet
underscore prefix variable so we'll do
subnet
underscore prefix and then we can set it
to whatever
value we want so i'm going to do the
10.0
dot let's do 100.0024
we'll hit yes
and now let's double check in the
console to make sure that this new value
got assigned
and so you can see here we've now got
our 10.0.100.0 so
the variable assignment that got
assigned
on the command line argument worked
now this is cool and all but uh you know
in reality i don't think we're going to
use either one of these methods to
assign variables
uh very often the best way to do it is
actually creating a separate file to
assign variables
and terraform automatically looks for a
file called terraform.tfvrs
for variable assignments so we can just
create that file now and we'll do
terraform dot tf vars
and here we can define a value for that
variable so i'm going to go back what
was it called
subnet prefix and so we'll do subnet
underscore prefix equals and then let's
give it the value that we want so we'll
do 10.0.200.0 just to
show that something has changed and so
i'm going to do an apply
without passing in an argument
and it looks like uh it's still looking
for
it's still asking for assignments so let
me cancel that i messed something up i
forgot to hit save probably yep
well let's just wait for that to finish
okay cancel that so hit save all
and so now because we've actually
defined this variable here it should not
prompt us for
uh for a value for that variable
okay and so let's hit refresh and let's
take a look at the value and so now it's
set to the 10.0.200.0
24. so those are really the three
different methods for assigning
variables
technically we can also use environment
variables from your operating system i'm
going to hold off on using that as an
example
or giving you an example of how to do
that because that's going to come into
play when we uh
worry about how we're going to store our
credentials for terraform instead of
just hard coding it into our terraform
file
so in in that scenario it's really good
to use environment variables so i'm
going to hold off on doing a demo of
that for now
now the next thing i want to cover is
well
first of all let's say that we didn't
want to use a
file called terraform.tfr let's say we
wanted to call it something else
or let's say we had multiple files for
multiple variables which is very common
especially when your terraform config
starts to grow
you know you don't want to store
everything in just one file well
we can tell terraform to actually look
for a specific file name so if i rename
this
actually before i do that i'm gonna do a
terraform destroy
all right and so now i'm going to rename
this
i'm going to rename this to let's just
say example.tfrs
okay
and now for terraform to actually look
for that file we have to explicitly tell
it to look for that file
and we can do that by passing in a
simple flag so i'm going to do terraform
apply
and we can pass in the flag dash var
dash
file and then we give it the name of the
file so we'll do example.tf bars
and so you can see that we didn't get
prompted to you know enter a value for
that variable because terraform was able
to look at this example.tfrs file
and find this value now in the earlier
parts of this video i did mention that
one of the options to pass into a
variable assignment is a default value
and so this
default value can be used if the user
doesn't uh input a specific value
and we can do an example of that just by
deleting this
right here we'll save that file and
let's just assign a default value so
we'll say default
equals 10 10.0.
66.0 24. so if the user doesn't input a
variable assignment
uh then terraform will automatically
assign this variable
this value so once we save that we can
then do a terraform
apply
and there you go so even without having
a value assigned to that
variable you can see that it still ran
and if we go to the
uh to aws console take a look at that
you can see a guy
assigned a value of 10.0.66.0 so this is
a way to apply a default value for a
variable
i'm going to remove this for now just so
i can do a few more
demonstrations using variables within
terraform i'm also going to rename this
so i don't have to keep
passing in a input argument
now i'm going to show you guys how to
actually perform a type constraint on a
variable so
in this case the subnet or the cidr
block needs to be a string
that holds the value of our subnet and
so we don't want to receive a variable
of any other type other than a string
and so what we can do is we can say type
equals string and so now
if i go to my terraform.tf bars and do a
subnet
underscore prefix equals and instead of
you know assigning you know 10. you know
0 to 0
24 something as a string let's say i try
to put in a list
and i try to assign this value
all right let's see what happens now
when we try to run that
oops it looks like string is not a valid
type specification so it must be a lower
s
a lowercase s
see and so now it throws an error saying
the given value is not a valid it's not
valid for a variable subnet prefix um
because it
it checks to see if it's a string and it
sees that it's not a string so it throws
an error so
this is just another way to make sure
that you know especially when you're
working on large code bases and you're
sharing the
your code with uh you know colleagues
this will just make sure that your
colleagues don't
accidentally uh you know input a wrong
variable type uh into a variable and
then
uh you know potentially see an error
when they run the config so it's just a
another sanity check that you can do
now while this is set to a list i want
to
uh show you guys how to actually use a
list as a variable
and so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to i've removed that type constraint and
i'm going to create a second subnet
and i'm just going to call this uh we'll
just call this a dev subnet
and we'll call this subnet 2.
and here we're going to specify the
cider block for both of those subnets so
i'll do 10.
0.1.0 and then for the second one we can
pass in a value of 10.0.2.0
24. we've got a list and now to
reference the list
all we have to do is just change this up
a bit so this is going to be
the first object in that list so when
you're working with lists
the first object can be referenced with
a zero then the second
one will be uh referenced with a value
of one and so on so it's just like any
other programming language
set that to one and let's give this a
shot and see if it works
and so now we've got our two different
subnets the prod subnet should be a
10.0.1.0
and the dev subnet should be at 10.0.2.0
all right and there's one more thing i
want to show you guys with variables
and i want to show you how to use
objects within variables
uh so right now we just have a list of
strings but we can also have
a list of objects too and so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to change
up the way i assign the tag so instead
of assigning
you know the tag or hard coding it what
i want to do is i want to have a
variable
that's going to look like this where
we're going to have an object and we'll
have two properties we'll have the
cider block and then we'll also have a
name property
and so that way the cider block will get
assigned to the cider block and the name
will get assigned to the name
and so we'll remove that we'll go back
to our terraform tfrs file and let's see
how we can actually do that
so here we'll create an object and we'll
assign it a
cider underscore block
should equal um and that's going to be
the 10.0.1.0.24
and then the next and then we have to
specify a name so we'll give it a name
and this is going to be rod
underscore subnet and then that's going
to be for subnet 1
and then for subnet 2 we'll do the same
thing
so we'll assign a property of cider
underscore block
and we'll set that equal to 10.0.2.0.24
and then the second property is going to
be the name
and that's going to be set to dev
underscore subnet
and so we're going to have to update a
few things here uh and so
under the cider block we want to grab
the
cider block property
and now for the name we're gonna have to
reference that variable
and we'll do a var dot
subnet prefix i'm going to grab the
first item
and we'll do dot name
and we'll copy this and just paste it
down here just make sure to update it so
it's the second object
yep and there you have it guys we were
able to now use a variable which is a
list of objects
to assign values uh within our terraform
configuration file so there's a lot of
flexibility with variables
uh you definitely want to make use of
them for as much as possible so that
you're not retyping the same thing over
and over
across large configs
and so just keep in mind i it was a
little confusing at first
for me especially because we have to you
know define the variable but we don't
assign it
here we have to assign it in the tf vars
file so just keep that in mind
in the tf files you define a variable
and then tf bars you actually assign it
a value